[Music]
Bachelorette Rachel she is down to her
final three but on Monday all the guys
she rejected are getting together for
the men tell all episode egl lines
lauren zima went behind the scenes of
the special and here's a preview
[Applause]
how would you describe tonight
specifically in a few words an arduous
journey it was wild it was it was
unexpected and I think unpredictable the
leftover is pulling no punches and
speaking their minds she's talking about
playing cat and mouse but it's like
Kenny may be the mouse but he's kind of
a the first time they've been able to
talk after watching it season and that's
what I think is so beautiful about
tonight because Leah I understand where
you're coming from but I feel like you
haven't acknowledged exactly what you're
we're trying to forgive you for Lee
specifically called out for some of his
behavior I think you're just saying I've
been a bad person but you're not
acknowledging the kind of invisible
racism in your mind I like that he was
responsive to it maybe he was giving us
lip service to and apologizing and maybe
he doesn't fully realize but I think it
was a good step for him tonight and who
are you okay never sing again I mean I
think that's pretty obvious Lee - Mario
you thought you could tell - girl you
were ready to wipe her when you were in
my bed I can't even look at you right
now were you surprised by how do Mario
really threw himself into this that's
your gonna say am i surprised how he
threw himself under the bus I mean I
really thought that he would come in and
be very contrite apologetic maybe even a
little quiet he was anything but but
what you will not see on Monday night is
the reveal of the next Bachelor Dean
Peter Brian Eric there's four great
candidates right there but in all
seriousness we've not picked a bachelor
so I can tell you no bachelor was chosen
we're gonna wait and just watch it all
play out